hello guys what's up I'm Ryan the right
hey everybody I'm Veronica got my
girlfriend here today yeah mmm give
daddy some sugar mm mm mwah come on baby
it's for the camera come on I didn't
know you're gonna do that no it's not a
script we're gonna talk about the video
today I type this in online cuz a lot of
people were telling me I should watch
this I there's like a [ __ ] ton of videos
of it Steve Harvey messes up on this
universe 2015 I don't know what he does
but supposedly this is a pretty
entertaining video kill all right let's
do this babes all right dude Columbia
one
I have to apologize No
the first runner-up is Colombia isn't
that what he said no she said she's the
winner
she won them boo-boos Pepito's in the
house I'm Filipino
way to go Philippines Radio Philippines
what she is hotter yeah
Filipinos beautiful ah 2015 this way to
go Philippines
way to go Philippines
oh my god
I don't care that you made a mistake
what matters is to Filipinos boy oh my
gosh dude you obviously don't understand
what's happening here
yeah I know she she really won the other
person see Harvey made a mistake
imagine how they're feeling right now
look at that reality TV that's reality
TV oh I can we just watch a little bit
of it again crazy I can't imagine that
happening on either side thinking that
you won the biggest beauty pageant in
the world suddenly all of that being
taken from you in front of everybody
okay let's break this video down a
little bit so she wins Philippines and
then her widow she yeah she was Columbia
Columbia they they hug all right good
good a little bit of lesbian action all
right
Columbia starts to get a little
teary-eyed I really want to put myself
in this situation I'm trying to
understand better Steve Harvey and then
comes and apologizes Philippines doesn't
even know exactly how to respond yeah
that was most captivating about her
experience you could totally see that
she's practically in shock the entire
time and then even when she goes up to
the stage
she's just Columbia's is just so upset
but Philippines isn't even like I don't
know their names I'm sorry you know what
it's like not even excited that she won
she kind of doesn't know what she should
do like she seems like she's aware of
how [ __ ] up it is what just happened
ooh yeah it must be a very uncomfortable
feeling like yeah I can't believe that
happened I'm sorry for talking so much
during the video I'm just really proud
of the Philippines I totally forgot that
this is a very traumatizing experience
for that woman from Colombia yeah an
amazing experience for this woman hear
that from the Philippines yeah the
Philippines Philippines are the best
that or Italy Italy wasn't runner-up
Philippines though way to go way to go
that's how we are I like to think that
the Philippines are kind of like the
rebellion against the Galactic Empire
you know the Galactic Empire seems like
oh it's going to win
but the rebellion might not have as big
of a chance but she want
way to go Philippines mad respect to my
brothers and sisters
anyway know what's happening you've
never shown so much Filipino pride
before well there's a reason to now and
with Manny Pacquiao wins fights you have
managed to annoy me so much this it
increases every word that comes out of
your mouth have you ever had something
like that happen to you before where
they tell you you won but you really
didn't no no but my sister's I don't
know like 12 almost 15 years ago
probably they they were in beauty
pageants it really took a toll on their
egos oh I've never heard of a person
just living a really good life and
really happy insecure I'm sure it exists
but I've never heard of a situation
where they're like really content with
themselves and self-confident and stuff
it tends to take a toll and make you
more self-conscious because so about
appearance hell yeah I mean it's all
about the way you look how you talk how
you your body how you look in a dress
how you look in a bikini if you have
talent it's like a judgement of their
entire being in front of a huge audience
but they choose that so they choose that
for themselves the what's really [ __ ]
up though is kids their parents putting
their kids into pageants yeah like that
little tiny baby bobber kids well it's
important to teach a woman you know when
they're young to how to be a woman when
they're older and it sounds like these
judging criterias are based off all the
things you should judge a woman based
off of right
listen guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to data the real
rejects Veronica has a channel on there
does a lot of vlogs and acoustic covers
as well you should check out her channel
let's do a shout out to the Philippines
Filipinos if you're a Filipino
subscriber you comment below and tell me
just how much you love this channel and
how proud you are to say that you're a
follower of the real rejects and it's
led by someone who is half Filipino you
tell me tell me do we have any female
Filipino subs do we have any gay male
Filipino subs because that's more of the
demographic that's not really a part of
this channel yet and I'm looking to get
more of that it's all about the gays